[Musique]
la mort du pompier Pierre Lacroix alors
qu'il tentait de secourir des
plaisanciers dans les rapides de la
Chine vaut aujourd'hui à la Ville de
Montréal une contravention pour ce type
d'infraction là en fait le montant s'est
écrit au communiqué de presse le montant
de la menthe peut varier entre 17000 680
dollars et 70000 727 dollars c'est que
le service de sécurité incendie de
Montréal le sim qui relève de la ville
et montrer du doigt par la cne-st pour
plusieurs lacunes dans sa gestion du
secteur nautique la formation déficience
des pompiers est sévèrement critiquée il
y a pas vraiment de suivi non plus au
niveau de la division nautique à savoir
si tous ces exercices là si s'il y a une
uniformité qui est appliquée la cnst
note aussi de sérieux problèmes avec les
Hammerhead les bateaux utilisés par le
Sim le bateau est un peu un arbre qui
cache le reste de la forêt dans le sens
que effectivement Yoss est limitation ce
bateau là a des défis
mais c'est pas le seul élément parce que
à ce moment-là un des éléments les plus
importants c'est que ces pompiers là
n'auraient jamais dû se retrouver aussi
loin aussi profondément dans la zone
d'interdiction l'équipage confirme la
cness.t affranchi la zone d'exclusion là
où les pompiers ont reçu l'ordre du Sim
d'une plus intervenir à la suite d'un
chat virement en 2010 la Zone Interdite
était censée se retrouver dans les GPS
elle ne s'y retrouvait plus
c'est important de tracer des ondes
c'est important de les mettre dans le
système de GPS mais il faut que les
travailleurs puissent se retrouver parce
que sur l'eau sans GPS devenir
identifier une ligne c'est impossible la
ville et le syndicat des pompiers
prennent acte de ce rapport mais demeure
prudent ils ont pris aucune moyenne
contrainte de forcer l'employeur des
corriger maintenant il est trop tôt pour
porter des conclusions mais nous irons
au fond de cette affaire la Ville de
Montréal 30 jours pour décider si elle
contestera cette contravention pour la
suite des choses elle préfère attendre
les conclusions de l'enquête publique
que la coronaire débutera au mois de
novembre ici Julie Dufresne Radio-Canada
Montréal